but what we're doing now a draft of the
most important non-quarterbacks for wild
card weekend chris has the trivia
question for me if i get it right i get
the first pick when i get it wrong he'll
get the first pick yep my man mike keith
on the on the call down there in
tennessee um with the exuberant
touchdown titans all right here we go
heisman trophy winner derek kennedy led
the league in rushing yards as you know
1540 yards okay
who i repeat who was the last heisman
trophy winner to win the rushing title
michael james florio
wow whoa oj simpson what you went that
far back really you just got to go i
figured it was a trick like that nope
all you just look at my school what
school did i go to oh oh ricky williams
yep good old ricky williams 2002 uh with
the miami dolphins i believe he's
disqualified he's disqualified why yeah
i'm kidding okay for for the reason
you'd be disqualified
yes he would we would both be
disqualified for those reasons you're
right you get the first pick all right
here we go um
you know it's it's really it's i don't
you know i don't like to be captain
obvious here with this one but derek
henry is probably the guy i'm gonna pick
number one i mean i am he is the guy i
am picking number one because he is the
most important non-quarterback you know
and maybe any game this whole weekend i
mean that's arguable arguable i
understand that but we know tennessee
tough task of going up to new england
winning that football game if new
england is susceptible in some areas it
is that i think you can overpower them
they lack big people on their defensive
front
which is unusual for them but if
tennessee and derrick henry can run the
ball
man that is going to put the patriots in
some sort of bind and of course ryan
tannehill and what they can do off a
play-action pass will become that much
more dangerous they'll be able to
control the clock do everything like
that so i go with derek henry
no bill belichick the coach of the
patriots was asked this week how do you
go about simulating derek henry in
practice and he said you can't it's
impossible and uh good luck getting
ready to face derek henry when he's
healthy he is as effective as any
running back in the nfl it's amazing he
isn't a bigger star
than he is yeah and maybe it's because
he plays for the titans and not for a
marquee team i mean think about if he
played for the cowboys if you play for
the patriots the packers the steelers
his jersey would be everywhere and we'll
see where he plays in the future because
i think the titans are going to do what
they can to keep him around if it means
using the franchise tag all right for me
i got to go dalvin cook we talked about
the viking saints game last segment and
if dalvin cook can run the ball the
vikings have a chance to keep it close
if he cannot get off the blocks if he
cannot push the pile if he can't dart
through those openings in that zone
blocking scheme that gary kubiak and
kevin stefanski use in minnesota the
vikings have no chance if they're forced
to be one dimensional passing the ball
they're dead so dalvin cook is going to
be key not to winning but to having a
snowball's chance in hell at staying
within a score and if that happens there
is a chance the vikings could stun the
saints but it's only going to be a
chance if dalvin cook is able to run
like we've seen him run on his good
running days all year long yeah a
hundred percent i hear you i think it's
the only chance exactly right i mean i i
feel like they gotta he's gonna have a
successful day just for them to keep
that game close is the way i feel about
it almost so
i'm with you um he has got to be special
and he has been special when healthy and
we'll see how that viking zo line does
against that saints d-line which is uh
the real deal holy field all right um
i think i'm gonna have to go with zach
ertz here for my second pick you know i
look at zach ertz i know he's coming off
a rib injury right it sounds like he's
good to go for the the match-up this
weekend against the seattle seahawks
there's lack of weapons with the
philadelphia eagles right now i mean we
know that the receivers are you know who
the hell knows their names okay and now
mile sanders is banged up as well on the
offensive side of the ball at the
running back position i just think that
means they're going to have to find more
and more ways to use zach ertz in the
middle of the field he had a pretty good
day the first time around against the
seattle seahawks i want to say he had
like north of 10 catches and stats maybe
you can look up that and look me that up
real quick but i do think that'll be an
important part of this game philadelphia
is going to have to run the ball a
little bit little play actions working
zacherts over the middle the seahawks
can be over aggressive stopping the run
at times which can let lend them to get
burned uh you know behind their
linebackers and i was right it was 12
catches first time around zachertz is my
second round pick
he was limited in practice on wednesday
with that rib injury i think i saw coach
doug peterson say that he has yet to be
cleared for
contact uh but yeah look this is the
playoffs this is a single elimination
round and uh you know i expected they're
there there is there is a very real risk
when you have a rib injury that you know
it breaks off and causes all sorts of
damage to your internal organs but i
don't know that that's going to be part
of the problem for earth's uh but but he
is critical to this if it's not him
dallas god it's a guy who's going to
have to step up and we saw goddard step
up i think that causes me and i want to
push a little bit here i don't think
arch is as important as you think
because i think goddard can get it done
but when there are so many guys who are
banged up for the eagles every guy who
can suit up and play helps i am gonna go
now with uh the first game of the
weekend the houston texans memorial
playoff game involving the houston
texans every year jj watts back
and
if if the texans are going to win this
game jj watt needs to re it can't just
be he's a decoy it can't just be he
needs a week or two to work himself back
into action he's got to come out and
he's got to be the jj watt of old so
you're playing that that implies you're
fine so you better come out and play
like you're fine and you better play
well because the texans are going to
need it if they're going to put together
the kind of effort total team effort
required to take down a very dangerous
bills team yeah no i i hear you i was
thinking about doing somebody along the
the texans defense too i couldn't i
actually was going to think about romeo
cornell just because hey this texans
defense it's all over the place all year
long uh but you're right they need j.j
watt not only as a pass rush president
pass rush
presence uh but you know because the the
texans pass defense it's one of the
worst in football and they need somebody
to rush the quarterback so they don't
have to compromise themselves of
blitzing and pressuring all the time to
try to make that happen that's a big
issue and uh that's one of the things
i'm interested in that matchup can that
bill's offense consistently move the
ball on that texans defense which has
been very spotty at best this year
um so good pick by you there i'm not mad
at you um let's see my third round pick
i'm not sure who i want wanna you know
what
i think i'm gonna go with nkeel harry
okay up in new england
because
new england who's gonna step up on that
offense who's it gonna be we know they
want to get the ball to julian edelman
but so does mike variable and dean peace
they know that too and i would be
thinking that they're going to steal
some of what they saw the houston texans
and kansas city chiefs do to the new
england patriots which is in big
situations they doubled julian edelman
they said prove to me you can beat me
with somebody else i feel like and kill
harry is very close to becoming that
next guy in that offense he's you know
just getting into shape missing so much
of the year but
new england needs that other viable
weapon in the pass game other than
edelman and i think nikhil harry could
be that guy especially this week with
the titans which don't have a great pass
defense they let up a lot of big plays
too he might get some favorable looks to
where brady wants to work him he's got
size and he can do something with the
ball in his hand so i look at him to be
a weapon this weekend mike
yeah and you know it's uh
who's it gonna be it's gotta be somebody
else
it's a harsh reminder for the patriots
that they could have had aj brown and
they took and kill harry and i'm going
to stick with that game yeah because i'm
flipping it over yeah to the guy that's
going to cover aj
because he got picked on last week and
it was not pretty when the dolphins
repeatedly targeted devontae parker who
was being covered by stefan gilmour can
stefan gilmore take some of the steam
out of aj brown right because if the
titans start running the ball
effectively with derek henry the passing
game should in theory open up and aj
brown has been spectacular this year
both he and dk metcalf came from the
university of mississippi and for a
while their stats were almost identical
a.j brown identical aj brown ended up
being the better guy this year and he's
had the moments he's had those like big
plays that we we see in the highlights
on football night in america and it's
like my god this guy's a man among boys
can stefan gilmore slow him down because
it could be that the patriots sell out
to stop derek henry and they say hey
stefan you handle aj brown and if he
handles him the way you handle devante
parker stefan gilmore is the one who's
going to be getting handled yeah that
that's what's scary it is because last
week you're i mean you know we watched
it together it wasn't like gilmore was
in bad pass coverage but it was just a
quarterback who was on fire against a
really talented receiver and they just
said you know the perfect throw and a
freaky athlete of receiver it's just
tough to stop i don't care who you are
and that's what you worry about right
now because you know you and i every
sunday we sit there every week and go
tana hill to aj brown holy cow i mean
it's becoming one of the marquee
combinations in the sport so i'm with
you that's why i was saying a little
earlier in the week mike like if i'm new
england i don't know on some of those
second downs i might double aj brown and
then say hey stefan gilmore go cover
corey davis on the other side and you
handle him but let's just take let's
take aj brown on a ryan tannehill's
thought process like pre-snap to where
he's like oh no i don't have my guy i
got to go somewhere else
that would be something i would think
about if i'm the patriots
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports